for a second day today americans will
pay their respects to justice ruth bader
ginsburg
lying in repose outside the supreme
court thousands stood in line yesterday
a slow and somber procession
against a backdrop of rapid activity
over ginsburg's replacement
the president plans to announce his
nominee he says on saturday
as jan crawford reports he's pushing the
senate to act very fast
i think the system is going to go very
quickly president trump who on wednesday
could not commit
to a peaceful transition of power if he
loses
said it's better if his supreme court
nominee is confirmed before the election
just in case it would be
more political than it should be i think
it's very important to have a
ninth chest as the president weighs his
options this week
the leading contender to replace justice
ginsburg is judge amy coney barrett
she's a favorite of the d.c republican
establishment
which is lined up to push her nomination
in 2016 following the death of justice
antonin scalia
barrett told cbsn she did not think
there's a clear rule for either side
in the debate over replacing supreme
court justices during an election year
it shouldn't be a surprise that the
senate is willing to push a president's
nominees through in an election year
when they share the same political
affiliation
on wednesday justice ginsburg arrived at
the supreme court for the last time
inside the great hall a private ceremony
for the eight justices
her family and her friends it has been
said that ruth wanted to be an opera
virtuoso
but became a rock star instead chief
justice john roberts spoke with
affection
as he honored ginsburg among the words
that best describe ruth
tough brave a fighter a winner
but also thoughtful careful
compassionate honest outside mourners
including
senators the clintons and vice president
mike pence paid their respects
as well as thousands of americans lining
up to say goodbye
to a hero of course she will live on in
what she did to improve the law
and the lives of all of us now justice
ginsburg will lie here in repose until
later tonight while the public
continues to pay its respects president
trump
is going to stop by at some point later
this morning to pay respects of his own
gail it's a very touching day yesterday
thank you very much jan